go read Las Vegas right now we have 24
hours to do every single thing that you
pick up because there's so much to do
here we're just gonna let strangers tell
us what to do and that's how we're going
to spend 24 hours people from the city
what should we do we're gonna do it
where's Burt
my son in Vegas no well they should have
it here because I'm burning
all right so we met some people at the
mega sign first recommendation what you
can do
fresh water yeah like so Peter
let's do it so we're at our first
destination the Graceland wedding chapel
the famous Graceland wedding chapel and
we're here to see about Vernon I don't
even go to weddings none of my friends
are married some hardly in relationships
let's get
[Music]
for me
[Music]
[Applause]
the wedding chapel
wedding vows and weirdly from Ireland a
boat
you know Irish people developers thank
you very much
close the power go stream understand
Urbana somehow husbands and wives kiss
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I like to think this was fate that
brought me here today I'm the only one
of us that's married and would come back
and renew my own vows hyundo percent
I'll call that a wedding it was like
multiple yeah that was like as efficient
as we could have been but we're looking
for the next place to go where's some
place you've dropped off a lot of people
go haunted Museum haunted Museum I feel
like we have to do that have you ever
been fortunate ly not have to talk a lot
of people off there and I'm an uber
drivers I'm just dropping people off
thinking about that's me
so as recommended we are at the haunted
Museum bit what does it say voted best
Museum in Las Vegas or in the world I
don't know it's best world
it just says best Museum so who knows
what that means let's go check it out
this are your eyes open no my eyes my
eyes are fully closed the Sun is
terrible I can't wear sunglasses because
nobody recommended that I buy sunglasses
all right so we're inside the museum and
we have station station he's gonna be
giving us a tour so how long have you
worked here I've been here since day one
October 30 2017 and it's already voted
the best Museum in Vegas oh absolutely
and you're gonna see why there are
pieces in here from serial killers we
have extraordinarily haunted pieces we
even have what's considered to be the
most haunted in Italy item in the entire
world and display deadly it is cause
death you're gonna see that in just a
little bit
[Music]
if you're unfamiliar with what a
difficult as a Jewish spirit that has
even though I'm doing I'm Jewish - I'm
is believe that has the power to possess
it we push it in our role to help their
unfinished business posts Malone had his
own encounter with the Dybbuk box and
since then has had extraordinary bad
luck
plane malfunctions car crash people
breaking into this home with guns he
blames this box for that curse
what exhibit so I'm not gonna force you
go in here this is I'm not going in
exhibit I'm going no I'm not tap out
[Music]
we're told that basically this box is
pure evil touch it don't touch it don't
I don't truly I don't want to look at it
too long the guard guys are ready yes
coming conjuring three movie which is
set for release next year's actually be
something said what I'm about to show
you now one of the famous keys they
hopped out with was 1980 it was called
the devil in Connecticut case this
became such a famous case because for
the first time in American history
demonic possession was used as defense
for hurt when the Beast was inside of
David would often sit in a rocking chair
this rocking chair was witnessed battles
rocking by itself back and forth all new
Atlantic team it would disappear and
then reappear again
David's brother said anyone even sit
this chair with something severe back
pain actually a friend sit this chair to
get back because but before she said
live like that my back has been hurting
in this room and I was waiting for you
to say something about back I'm not even
I swear on my life I was like that was
hurting so bad now about to present to
you door opens you want your actual
audio from the exorcism and it's
extraordinarily disturbing
I felt like I was gonna faint multiple
times I feel like we need like a cleanse
to get away from this so you know the
rules of the video where was the last
place you ate we're gonna go there
evil pie pizza evil plan we turn evil
great of course
do you just evil I'm like I can't do
anymore you know is that like as haunted
as this or no it's just like Evel
Knievel kinda okay I'm good I'm gonna
get ya I need like new energy I need
something to like replenish my spirits I
think that'll be good too
all right so we're at the pizza place
that was recommended what you call evil
pie pizza in Vegas downtown Vegas so hi
Dan Chris got some basic pizza by
Spencer night we're adventurous I got
what is this grasshopper beats a
grasshopper beats and rattlesnake I am
petrified of snakes and I got a
rattlesnake
he sucks I'm trying to conquer my fears
I'm trying to get the snakes Cheers
[Music]
oh really go then rattlesnake bite
wait this would see it juicy bro grab
one you gotta try just try it just try
it
I'm into it with that that was a
possessively good recommendation
Evel Knievel feat the shop I would jump
the moon on a motorcycle for this pizza
we're here with our driver what do you
think we should go for the final
activity end of the day and Las Vegas
think you guys should definitely check
out the stratosphere definitely do the
bungee jump on the top of the
stratosphere yeah I think that should be
definitely cool for you guys before you
leave is something that is pretty neat
yeah we've done it personally I have not
done it but you guys should do it I'm
too tired so they're gonna explain
what's happening next we have reached
the end of our insane day of just
following strangers directions
recommendations you should do that we
haven't we don't know what's gonna
happen but we do know what's about to
happen we're gonna jump off a building
that's the most wild thing I have ever
done this may be the last thing I've
ever done but it's not gonna happen say
that what do you think it's scarier this
stratosphere jump or
the haunted hotel not me a haunted
I mean the haunted Museum truthfully I
think they are close reason finalist I
honestly thought the wedding chapel is
kind of scary but this
I'm not scared of fear I'm scared of
humans and human error and like whenever
I'm in rollercoasters I always like
think that thing is gonna come off I'm
gonna find works or family friends just
in case you don't make it back alive
this is how I would have wanted to go
don't make a mess for me at the bottom
all right no promises
starting to sweat a little bit although
nervous I'm super stressed I was not
stressed before but now that I'm excited
I'm very stressed
it's like weirdly calming out here
here he comes to the window
[Music]
Jesus I have no moisture in my mouth huh
it's all gone that adrenaline rush my
hands like us shaking a little bit
I can't even this is not faking this is
100% real I was going down so fast and I
was like when when do I slow down I did
not think he was gonna stop at the end
like you're getting really close to the
ground and it just keeps going and then
cruel just pulls her insides out it was
just like beautiful I don't know what
else we already jumped off this very
high buildings and then Eric was like I
want to go higher how can I get higher
so it's like why don't we launch Eric
straight up off the top of the building
in Spencer just a casualty and Spencer
there's a switch
from option down where you just
experienced it's called puberty
I think that's the number one day I
think we already had enough
recommendations I need someone to
recommend me to my bed because I'm tired
I am dead and it's three hours ahead our
time so it's really the next day for us
I I need some sleep we have a big day
tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]